قمه بين الحليفين الوثيقين منذ تمرد
مجموعه فاجنر في يونيو حزيران الماضي بحث
الرئيس الروسي وفلاديمير بوتين مع ناظره
البيلاروسيه الكسندر لوكاشينكو اخر تطورات
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وصف بوتين خلال
القمه التي عقدت في الهجوم الاوكرانيه
المضاد بالفاشل مضيفا ان قواته دمرت عددا
قياسيا من الاسلحه الاجنبيه خلال ساعات
الماضيه من جهته اكد الرئيس البيلاروسيا
بلاده تسيطر على قوات فاجنر وتمنعها من
التوجه الى بولندا مشيرا الى ان خسائر
القوات الاوكرانيه منذ الرابع من يوليو
تموز الجاري بلغت 26 الف عسكري وحذر
لوكاشينكو منيه النيتو ضم الجزء الغربي من
اوكرانيا الى بولندا حسب تصريحه
قوات بدات تقلقنا فهم يريدون الذهاب الى
الغرب ويطلبون الاذن بذلك سالتهم لاي غرض
قالوا انهم يريدون الذهاب في رحله الى
وارسو وجيشوب جيشوف بالنسبه لهم امر حساس
فعندما حاربوا في بخموت كانوا يعلمون من
اين تصلوا الاليات العسكريه ولذلك فان هذه
المنطقه كارثه بالنسبه لهم بالطبع احاول
السيطره عليهم وابقائهم في مركز بيلاروسيا
لا اريد اعاده نشرهم هناك لانهم مستاءون
ولابد من الاشاده بهم فهم يدركون جيدا ما
يحدث حول دوله الاتحاد